let's go to the 90s and let's talk about
dr quinn oh you're interested or not
[Music]
the first thing i remember is that my
ex-husband at that time had lost all our
money left me nine million in the red
with lawsuits from every major bank
michaela quinn and byron sully now come
to be joined
give me the dr quinn tea the scoop the
secret that you haven't divulged
all these years later never fall in love
with your leading man
in the pilot and then break up before
they pick it up
[Music]
these are the real clothes from dr quinn
this is this shirt i used to wear all
the time the waistcoat
[Music]
i'm going to be 70. i'm actually quite
proud of it really because
i don't feel like i'm 70 and i certainly
haven't you know
given up
you started your career working at james
bond
yes what do you remember about that
i never let die cannot see when you are
this way with me
first of all i was not available for it
so i'd already turned down the interview
and so the second time i was asked to go
i showed up and uh
the producer rather sort of aggressively
said take off your coat take up your hat
and so i took off my coat took off my
hat
and my hair came tumbling down you know
beneath my my backside
and they offered me the job on the spot
so i thought oh
so that's how you get the lead in a
bonfire when i went to do the the movie
they decided they didn't like the way i
looked and they had
got this costume designer and make up
people who had made me look a certain
way
and they said you look so much better
last night at the party they grabbed my
suitcase
and took all my clothes and remade them
and i ended up
helping to design the white dress
so i ended up designing or helping to
design
substantially my wardrobe on my first
film when i was 20.
and so because of that i have always
brought with me my own wardrobe to
every movie i've ever been on just in
case
wow at the time did you realize how
iconic that would be
well i did know that being a bond girl
in england
is like huge yes put down those cards
it is a blasphemy i mean it was absurd i
mean everyone knew
who the bond girls were but the other
side of it was you know bond girls
weren't necessarily supposed to be
playing shakespeare and
ibsen and going into the theater and i
kind of broke the mold and i said thanks
very very much but i've now had the
experience of running three paces behind
a man
in high heels with a gun and i don't
have the gun i just got split skirt and
a lot of cleavage no i think i'm going
to play lady macbeth and ophelia
and you know do the doll's house and do
do the classic so
i kind of um went a different way and a
lot of people said oh you know she's
failed she'll never work because
you know she's walked away from this big
role but um
that was how i educated myself let's go
to the 90s
and let's talk about dr quinn michaela
quinn
md what's the first memory that comes to
mind
when you think of that show in that
character the first thing i remember is
that
my ex-husband at that time had lost all
our money left me nine million in the
red with lawsuits from every major bank
including the fdic i was homeless
penniless
called my agent and said i would do
anything he called the networks and they
said
how about a little movie of the week but
she has to sign for five years in case
it becomes a series
she has to start tomorrow morning you
know less than 12 hours from now and
uh that was it dr quinn that's how i
remember it
he they saved my life i i had a i got a
room
you know a roof over my head i got some
money so i could get back on my feet
and my kids could come out to the set
and do the school work in the
trailer and um and they wrote the most
beautiful material ever
i mean that you know you watch doc quinn
now
and it's just so on point to what's
happening today
it dealt with everything it racism um
gosh bigotry um um you know alternative
medicine
um you know immigration it was
an amazing experience when you look back
to that time when you had nothing and
you're sitting here today
out looking over one of the most
spectacular views do you feel like
you appreciate it so much more because
you have been in that situation where
you're like
i could be in big big trouble i pinch
myself every day when i wake up i look
out the window and i see the dolphins
jumping i see the pelicans flying by
i realize i'm eating food that i grow in
my garden
i just i just can't believe it honestly
every single day
but you know i do work hard and but i
was
incredibly fortunate to get dr quinn
incredibly fortunate
what was it about dr quinn that you
think
captured people's imaginations uh first
of all there was a really gorgeous guy
called joe lando
playing a man called summy and i think
most of the women went oh yes
well if you're gonna survive you better
learn to make it on your own
so who took that box um but i think it
was really
it really dealt with the human condition
the human experience
and i think what was brilliant about it
was it was set in 1870 but
it's the same stories that we deal with
daily so
i think uh uniquely it was material made
in america
that translated to 98 different
countries
it still plays in 98 countries so
everyone could relate to it is there a
moment or a scene
that you remember when you were like oh
my gosh
this show it's gonna go when i read it
i was of course you know in the lowest
depths
of despair personally in my life and
i've read this script
and i just it totally took me away and i
wept uncontrollably but in a beautiful
way and uh
when i saw the pilot it you know it had
the same effect and every time
we had a read through for dr quinn and
we'd just be reading around the table
you know the tears would flow and i just
thought if it feeds me
at the lowest ebb in my life it must
possibly
be able to feed the spirits of other
people
okay i want to take you back
i want to show you this one when we were
on the pilot we had a flash flood in
which i was
rather dramatically swept backwards in
the cadillac into a
four foot torrent of water and uh was
nearly struck by lightning so
around here on this show you never know
what you're gonna get
i remember that um a flash flood came
through
and i've never seen a flash flood it
looked pretty bad to me and there's lots
of you know the houses are on sticks
and and all the um the rocks are sliding
like crazy
jeff segality was the head of the
network and his nephew had the job of
being my personal driver in a cadillac
and he did not want to lose his job so
he had not let me out of the car
and i eventually managed to get a window
down and i climbed through the window
into joe lando's
very big you know monster truck
literally climbed from that window and
then i remember
that he got me out of there and we
discovered some tequila
the car the car floated backwards and
crashed into the
so the car was done it was gone yes and
i think it actually crashed into the
catering truck which was even more
devastating
we had a lot of scary stuff happen you
know we had rattlesnakes every day
someone said you're out and about you
were out and about fires
we had a brilliant dp the skies are
black there are fires
all around us okay and the ash
is landing on our heads and i look like
i'm in a christmas scene
and we are still shooting because he's
managed to light it
i don't know how they did it do you have
a favorite moment a favorite scene
i i actually liked it when i gave birth
by the side of the tree and had to get
sully to be the doctor for a change
and um i remember at the time i i were
joe and i were not getting along quite
as well as we should have been
and uh in the middle of the scene i
grabbed him by the cheeks
like you know like a woman having labor
pains but i squished his face
i knew he wouldn't like it but we're
very good friends now but i
i was a bit naughty actually oh really
just a bit naughty
now what would be a good thing a nice
thing to say probably the wedding that
was that was fun
that's one of the most famous episodes i
think actually the most moving one for
me was swashita
that was incredible the um you know the
washita when they
killed all the native americans that was
very real what was it like being on the
set and working with all those folks and
you guys
you guys were doing something that was
really historically important
we knew it was good material we were
thrilled we had an audience because we
were never expected to get an audience
charlotte there's been a terrible
mistake just a small misunderstanding
really well see i thought that miss
quinn was a man
i mean i assumed when she answered the
advertisement that she was a doctor
i am a doctor we were told a woman in
the lead wouldn't work you know a period
piece a western
a medical show you know ticked all the
boxes for a disaster and not a good
series so
we were very very grateful very thrilled
but our set was like a family
we were out in a in a you know a
national park
but the fans came from all over the
world and just stood there watching us
morning noon and night so it was almost
like a live show
although it was being filmed fans could
just find you
and come out and watch dr quinn yes with
long lens cameras so there was no
privacy at all
and but those fans i think
were so touched by the fact that we
would find time to go over and say hello
and take pictures with them
that they became our die hard fans that
we still have today and if we hadn't had
those fans
globally and they came from all over the
world to watch us filming
we would not have had the success that
we had i am astounded that all the shows
have been brought back
that's the one that hasn't it's bizarre
to me it's it's a no-brainer really
could there be a reboot a maybe a dr
quinn movie or something in the works
you know what we've got one already
written beth sullivan's already written
one
all the cars are happy to come back
we've uh
pitched it but um
i don't know i think it's sort of in the
hands of whoever wants to make it and
the legal teams that decide on who
actually owns it
ah okay okay the everybody who created
it and everybody who's in it
we're all completely ready wow where
would it pick up
it would pick up 26 years later so it's
turn of the century
and a lot of women's rights and a lot of
activism that was going on at that time
so a lot of issues that we're dealing
with today were happening right then so
it would be so
so appropriate okay you talked about you
being naughty
tell me what you meant like give me the
dr quinn t
the dr quinte from back in the day the
scoop the secret that you haven't
divulged
all these years later oh i'm sure
everyone knows everything well
um okay so
never fall in love with your leading man
in the pilot
and then break up before they pick it up
we're telling the world that we belong
to each other so what happened
we spent seven years of
not being together except on camera
how crazy was that that was completely
crazy i mean
literally crazy he is now joe and i are
the closest people
on the planet we adore each other our
families have grown up together it's
great but
i don't know what happened there but you
know we fell madly in love ran off to
bora bora
um he realized that everyone recognized
me even in
you know middle of nowhere um and he
realized that
you know that wasn't going to work so
that was it
and then they picked up our show
so so all that sexual tension you saw
it was real i would call it more tension
sexual anyway whatever it was it worked
because when i watched that stuff
i remember not even talking to him and
then
you know we'd be feeding one another
berries and
and be half naked jumping off cliffs and
you know kissing and everything
and and the thing that made it even
funnier was that
uh my then husband uh james keach was
directing the episodes
so i broke up well joe and i broke up
and then prop
you know pretty immediately afterwards i
met james keach and then
we were together and that was it so when
we were filming the series james keach
was one of the regular directors on it
you need anything you just ask
and here to direct joe and i making up
i know so is there ever any like they s
he says cut and everybody just goes
their separate ways
oh yeah yeah it was really awful
i i mean i there were tears cried i tied
man you tried me
you know it's something i i think when
you love someone you always love them
and i think
um you know he absolutely it was the
right thing that we
you know we ended our relationship then
because it
could never be a marriage it couldn't
but best friends great was there ever a
time where your husband said
do you really have to kiss him like that
no he said you'd better kiss him like
really james has directed me in so many
things and i've had to kiss so many
people
on his instructions and quite often
friends of you like the famous one with
the
was um was it barry bostwick i think
or i can't remember or was it well one
one of these guys and
we were in a bed scene i can't remember
what it was and
and um this guy just took off his
shorts and threw them at james
and he went like ah what's that and the
crew are going oh my gosh you know
thinking now he's naked in bed with me
right because he wasn't he was wearing
another pair of hats but he didn't know
crew didn't know i knew but
yeah it can get a little uh acting a
little crazy
at one point you became the highest paid
woman in television um what was that
like that was just amazing
i mean it was completely thrilling and i
don't think i
i really realized it and you know
when i did i just thought well i have to
work even harder now because they're
paying me so well
i don't think i was as high paid as
friends friends was off the charts
i know that roma downey came in straight
after us
yeah with touched by an agent yes and
she ended up wearing my clothes
what in one episode one time i saw i
said well that's my outfit she was
wearing
first of all how did you keep these
outfits okay well um
the uh the costume designer
is uh my closest friend and uh we were
all convinced
that we were going to come back so the
idea was if we all kept a few of our
classic pieces that if we suddenly did
come back we'd
have the wardrobe and it wouldn't be
just dispersed into some costume house
somewhere
sherry ingle who designed was the
designer on the show and was actually
nominated for an emmy for designing
um has been my business partner we've
been working together ever since so
i work with her every single day so we
know these costumes well they live up in
my attic and
i don't know how many do i have i have
too many
do you want to look at some clothes so
this is amazing because
these clothes are iconic these are the
real clothes from dr quinn this is this
shirt i used to wear all the time the
waistcoat
these are kind of fun you know it's a
split skirt thing
with real leather and this thing this is
quite heavy yeah
it's and i wear it all the time in the
heat right
in the heat yes all right so this is
pretty iconic dress you see it's it's a
skirt in the top
um but uh yeah i always wore this over
everything pretty much
i was told by the costume designer that
if i had space to keep them in case we
came back
would i be prepared to look after them
and i said yes so that's what i'm doing
i'm looking after them
you know what's a fun fact about this is
these laces
i used to buy them in england when i
lived in england and i used to buy
fabrics to make dr quinn dresses
including
a lot of the fabric for the wedding
dress sherry was brilliant she got
nominated for an emmy for best costumes
quite rightly we're not here hiding okay
so can we can we talk about this
is from one of my favorite movies of all
time
i want to be everything to you you are
you are this is the waistcoat from
summer and time that christopher reeve
wore
and he took a penny out of it and then
left me
forever yeah and this and he gave it to
me chris took it out of his wardrobe and
he said i want you to have this
i gave him a gold watch by the way
tell me about chris and what made him so
special
well we had a magical experience making
somewhere in town
and when we were making it this is
another
true confession that you get we fell
madly in love and we were both single at
the time
and uh had no reason why you know that
couldn't work out
but later on something happened so we
we couldn't be together anymore so it
was kind of a bit like the film
and um but we remained really really
really close friends until the day he
died
and so those scenes they were real that
was real
oh yeah no wonder we're so doggone good
it's so good the chemistry
so there's a famous scene after we've
made love yes
and it's a picnic scene we're having a
picnic on the floor got pockets
everywhere
i could pull rabbits out of here oh yeah
this is the best part there's a special
coin compartment for emergency
and then at the end of it he says talks
about his opposite what's wrong with
this and he pulls out the penny
just before we did that scene i found
out the reason why
we could never be together again
because his ex-girlfriend was having a
baby
wow so you're in that scene my heart was
broken
broken you can see the tears if i look
in the scene
and you go in the close-up you can see
the tears just coming because i'm not
supposed to be crying i'm very happy
you know it's like the waterworks are
like just coming up halfway up my
eyeballs
how did you do that scene with great
difficulty
i'll never forget it it was one of the
toughest things i've ever done in my
life
it was really really hard and you're in
that atmosphere that is so beautiful and
everything was so perfect
yeah it was very very hard if you could
go back
now today and you could
see your 20 year old self what would you
say to her
i would say do not fall in love with
your leading man okay
it is not a good well sometimes it's a
good idea
but not really no no it's messy
you have a milestone birthday coming up
i do what does it mean to you
i am hopefully going to be alive that
would be a good start
i'm going to be 70. um i'm actually
quite proud of it really because i don't
feel like i'm 70 and
you know i certainly haven't you know
given up you have
been in hollywood all this time but you
remain this sex symbol
if you say so listen the other day i
i was watching my teenage kids
watch um wedding crashes and they just
couldn't stop with the kick kid
this is clear i don't call me cat okay
cat call me
well i mean that was a great movie and
that was the best part in my opinion i
just thought that scene was
incredible and uh after that i've done
nothing but
a ton of comedy i'm doing comedies all
the time and
and i love it i love being completely
outrageous and i love playing all those
cougars i mean i've done
so many of them i think at one point
james keach did say to me can we like
cool it with the cougars now
i said hey you know who gets asked to to
work at all at my age
this is nice this is fun i'm enjoying
myself and it's a funny side of you that
we get to see
a very different side very yes
very different side of me exactly and in
fact when i read
wedding crashes the first time um i
thought oh gosh i can't possibly do this
i've just done dr quinn you know
those fans all over the world they'll go
crazy because they don't
even go to r-rated movies you know what
they think and then i read it again and
i was
howling with laughter and i just thought
i've got to do this so i auditioned for
it by the way you know a lot of other
people tried out i got lucky
and um and and i you know
it gave me a whole new career um
i've had times in my life where one
thing just changes everything you know
that
some people worry about you know they
they have one career and then it's over
you know i had the the virgins i played
a lot of virgins
all the way up to dr quinn at 45 i was
still a virgin
just remember the time frame it's crazy
and
um and then you know and villains and
victims and uh
and now i you know play grandmothers and
i you know put a grey wig on i can
do love scenes with alan arkin
and get nominated there you go so the
all you need is a grey wig